THAT GUY.
GET RID OF THIS GUY.
HERE IS DAN HOFFMAN AND MIKE
WALT YOUR TAKE ON CONCERNED THA
MEC PROBABLY GAVE INTO SOME
PRESSURE ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN RIGHT.
>> OF COURSE YOU WANT EVERY
AMERICAN HOME APPEARS IN
DICTATORSHIPS, APPEASING
TERRORISTS ARE NEVER ANY
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES
FOR ANY REASON THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN, THE TALIBAN, THE NORTH
KOREANS CONTINUE TO TAKE
AMERICAN AFTER AMERICAN HOSTAGE
IS EVENTUALLY THEY HOLD ONTO
THEM LONG ENOUGH THEY DID GET
ENOUGH, WE CAVE WE GIVE THEM A
BETTER DEAL HOW ABOUT THIS QUIC
HOW ABOUT YOU DON'T LET PUTIN
DICTATE THE TERMS FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE SECRETARY SAYS HERE WERE
THE CHOICES THE RUSSIANS GAVE U
VERY HOW ABOUT WE DICTATE THE
TERMS?
ABOUT EVERY TERRORIST GROUP
DICTATOR SHOOT OUT THERE THEY
KNOW THEY TOUCH AND HAIR ON
AMERICANS HIGH AND THE COST WIL
BE SO HIGH, ECONOMICALLY AND
DIPLOMATICALLY LIVE A MILITARIL
THAT THEY DON'T DARE TOUCH
ANOTHER AMERICAN, BUT WHAT HE
HAS DONE TONIGHT MAYBE A TACTFU
TODAY IS GOING TO RESULT IN MOR
AND MORE AND MORE AMERICANS
BEING TAKEN HOSTAGE DOWN THE
LINE BECAUSE THEY KNOW, AT THE
END OF THE DAY THERE IS AN
UPSIDE BUT NO DOWNSIDE WHETHER
IT IS PUTIN, THE IRANIAN REGIME
MY HEART BREAKS FOR THE PAUL
WHELAN FAMILY AND FUTURE
AMERICANS.
>> SO DAN HOFFMAN, WE HAD THE
MERCHANT OF DEATH VIKTOR BOUT
ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST NOTORIOUS
ARMS DEALERS YOU GET BRITTNEY
GRINER WHO IS CHARGED WITH A
DRUG VIOLATION, A MINOR ONE, SH
GOT NINE YEARS IN PRISON BUT
THEN YOU HAVE A MARINE WHO HAD
BEEN HELD BY THE RUSSIANS SINCE
2018.
WHY DID HE NOT HOLD OUT FOR BOT
BEFORE GIVING UP THE MERCHANT O
DEATH SEEMS LIKE A HORRIBLE DEA
FOR THE U.S. FOR EVEN THE AND
VERY GLAD THAT BRITTNEY GRINER
IS HOME I HAD SAID MANY TIMES
THAT I HOPE WE GET HER OUT OF
THERE.
>> I THINK WE CAN HAVE BOTH OF
THOSE, MAKE BOTH THOSE
CONCLUSIONS TONIGHT WE CAN BE
THANKFUL THAT BRITTNEY GRINER I
HOME BUT BE UNHAPPY WITH THE
DEAL.
VIKTOR BOUT WASN'T JUST THE
MERCHANT OF DEATH BUT HE ALSO
SERVED IN THE SOVIET ARMY.
AT THE SAME TIME, OUR FORMER
MILITARY OFFICER, PAUL WHELAN,
MARINE STILL LANGUISHING IN A
RUSSIAN VISIT VERY I AM WORRIED
ABOUT HIS HEALTH THEY HAVE RAPI
COVID THERE.
VACCINE RESISTANT TUBERCULOSIS
ALL THE THINGS IN A PENAL COLON
WHERE HE IS LIVING.
I DON'T WANT TO DISPARAGE THE
NEGOTIATORS.
I AM SURE THEY DID THEIR BEST.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE GOTTE
BOTH OF THEM APPEAR GOING TO
GIVE UP THIS GUY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN